twenty-four hours ago he wasn't even in
the running but on Thursday Hasan Diab
was appointed Lebanon's new prime
minister and given the difficult task of
leading the country out of its worst
political crisis in decades
dear Lebanese our efforts should focus
on preventing the collapse and restoring
confidence and safeguarding national
unity by consolidating bridges of
Understanding between all Lebanese
people political and security stability
is a priority today and it is a
cornerstone for the protection of their
country five years ago mr. diab served
as education minister energy Beckett's
government now he's promised to be a
unifying force and has asked the country
to bury its divisions and give him a
chance not everyone is prepared to do
that many see him as part of the old
political order they want overhauled
want someone that resent as you know and
as how can I say it's not rated to
anyone from all the parties and all the
politicians in this country and doesn't
belong to the old sectarian regime and
the idea is that we've been 60 days on
the streets and we our demands are very
clear Lebanon has suffered from nearly
two months of often violent and
disruptive street protests over
government corruption spiraling
inflation and a dire economic situation
but there are those who believe mr. Diab
can succeed Lebanon is suffering serious
monetary and economic pressures and
risks a social explosion the current
social revolution may lead to insecurity
and instability and we all have to help
the app is a technocratic specialist and
everyone should understand that the
former University professor was not
elected unanimously the large
influential sunny bloc led by the former
prime minister Saud Hariri did not
support mr. D AB or nominate its own
candidate he was backed by the
predominantly Shiite Hezbollah alliance
the media in Israel has already
described Mr D AB as Hezbollah's man and
this shows that as well as dealing with
Lebanon's pressing domestic issues he
must also juggle the interests of
outside powers such as Iran Syria the US
and Israel which have all played a part
in the country's political instability
hours after mr. D AB accepted the
nomination people were still out
protesting although in fewer numbers but
in sunny areas of Beirut and Lebanon's
second largest city Tripoli there were
reports of roads being blocked and tires
being burnt
mr. Diab will begin talking to all
parties this weekend but it's clear that
not everyone wants to listen there's
still a lot of talking to be done before
Hassan diab is able to head a new
government and that process can still
take months but the question is how will
his nomination translate for the
Lebanese people and will it be enough to
stop their violence and the
demonstrations Tony barfi al Jazeera
Beirut